[Applause]
a provocative rock song from italy won
an unusual eurovision song contest
showing a nerf wrecking final france and
switzerland came in second
and third the stage in rotterdam seemed
to explode to show europe's largest
music event was back
after a year of absence due to the covet
pandemic
a relatively small audience faced some
restrictions and testing
but that did not ruin the party of
pyrotechnics glitter lalalas
and at times quirky tunes
it's epic i love the eurovision song
contest already and when the netherlands
won
i was really excited but the pandemic
has become
a bit of a party pooper covet infections
are still high in the netherlands and
organizers have put rigid testing in
place hospitals appeal to the
authorities to hold a festival
without an audience but the mayor
insists it's safe to let 3500 tested
people attend
the large hospital of the netherlands
the erasmus medical center
gave me the guarantee that they have
enough capacity to deal with it if there
is any
of such an event happening it's about
bringing
peace and bringing hope in a lot of
homes and of citizens in the world
despite his
very worst time that were passing um the
covet
but also the the war in the middle east
of a new
age many dutch were rooting for jungu
mccoy he stayed mostly inside his hotel
room in the run-up to the contest to
prevent getting infected
i realized that that is a very different
eurovision than you know what
people are used to but for me it's my
first
experience of experience um i hope that
you know because
there this is this is a test event that
um the results are positive um
and that that it gives us more freedom
more than before
music has become a medicine during this
year's eurovision song contest and while
the festival is meant to bring europe
together
social distancing rules are keeping
these country teams mostly apart
but the show must go on and it
definitely does
[Music]
[Applause]
with a 20 million euros budget the
netherlands has gone out of its way to
try and make the estimated 200 million
viewers worldwide
forget about the pandemic
but for some it's more about the
costumes than the music
step fast from al jazeera rotterdam